agora qual o pessoal domingos a mais um
vídeo e os peões finais como fazer uma
águia e uma bainha é bem é o lugar onde
se guarda é a briga ou então espada e
que dá para aprender ao cinto
aí pra fazer isso usar de folhas e fita
primeiro grau foi a alma está a usar e
como folha a4 30 pessoas mas vocês podem
usar outra qualquer
dobre quase pra linha do centro deixam
que a distância entre a linha vincada em
final de folha dólares por cima da linha
em cada e de voltas até chegar à linha
docente e claro agora fazer o mesmo por
outro lado não esquecendo deixar aquela
distância outra vez
feito isto vou fazer dois triângulos
retângulos para linha do centro sobre
foi uma parte à outra e prendendo usando
fita 81 podem usar cola é e convicções
de uma fita transparente para nós lutar
muito e atenção pessoal vou te tirar a
ponta para não ficar perigoso agora
envolve uma folha com sua sombra em
favelas das feiras e prendam com fita
isso porque para forçar a lâmina pela
ficar mais resistente por dentro da
lâmina e prendam com fita de maneira que
fico cabo centralizado ipt em um pedaço
de papel pra ficar o carro mais grosso
embaixo existentes e prendeu no final
com fita dobre no folha online
e vejam a largura da família quando
marcarem linha é só dobrar até o final
para finalizar muito das fitas para
aprender tudo já está aqui foi da atria
podem colar a peça para um único lado
nesta para vão ter que deixar uma
distância maior que deixaram
inicialmente para que é a água que entra
dentro da bahia até em seguida é fazer o
mesmo processo tudo igual
a única diferença é que vocês vão deixar
aquela dizem ser maior
agora o senhor for uma parte a outra em
prender usando fita e nesta parte não
podem usar cola tem que ser mesmo fita
porque cola pode entrar lá dentro e não
vai deixar eles podem entrar dentro
agora eu fiz esta coisa aqui que sempre
vai explicar como é que é
tece uma espécie de argola e depois eu
dobrei de maneira que fique um retângulo
aqui para aprender sempre
desta maneira eles aos ganhos ao fim os
pés do estado e vocês quiseram mesmo
deixar nossa linha vostro favorita se
inscreva no canal que isto ajuda
bastante na divulgação evolução do meu
trabalho e isso pronto um grande abraço
e até a próxima etapa